pink pink pink a anything KK let's get
to that topic of how's that rosewater oh
my god no no there's a like onyx tiny
glasses those are my glasses looks like
it rains look at that where we spray
rosewater on each other's faces this
episode of the Gillian podcast Marvel's
left
you know the chromecast when you like
join and like yeah yeah you know you
know talking to Comcast and then you
will sign out yeah it's really funny
sometimes we'll be in the living room
watching it and I'll say Julian left
like Marvel Julian podcast starts Marvel
s this episode is brought to you by this
skin do you guys want your news waiting
for you when you wake up in the morning
do you want to read it in five to ten
minutes yeah be smarter yeah but with
any conversation yeah well then join the
skin that's a free newsletter with all
the top news and everything that you
need to be informed to start your day go
to the skim that's th e sk IMM comm /gen
Julian to get started not a free trial
it's free just get started
author brought you by tracker pixel this
is the new member of the tracker family
it is tinier it is more powerful and it
is doper hmm that's weird
I don't know where my phone is oh my god
your phone from the tracker and you can
page the tracker from your phone so you
attach tracker pixel which is their new
tiny tracker to any device that you tend
to lose keys wallets even your hamster
we can put one on out here by rail meg
fad it's probably little bit
it affects parallel bait and I will
definitely be putting one of these on my
brand new drone because I'm not losing
that cake so if you have something you
lose a lot and you don't want to lose
anymore get the tracker pixel I'm
telling you guys this is an incredible
product this is a new and improved
version of the tracker which is already
great so go to the tracker that's th e
TR ACK our comm promo code generally and
get 20% off any order right now thank
you yeah
you know we're going to talk about some
dad stories today the three human guys I
had a nice long conversation with my dad
on Father's Day and he said that they
have a tracker on their cat oh my god
they're so funny I'm Tessa Gracie and
outdoor cat yeah so and he was like you
have to make sure that she doesn't leave
the house like on a full stomach girl so
let me come back so fun did he find out
about from the podcast I think so but do
you know that she likes to go she's a
peeping tom his cat he liked his
neighbor told him recently that like
they're in their second-story like
bedroom his neighbor was getting dressed
like for work and took a picture of her
and she just sits outside with the
stairs that I'm going in my dress like a
peeping cat creep
that is absolutely creepy that's what I
mean I would completely probably cat out
probably something like that dude me to
get away with every year [ __ ] animal
you're all uqu you're spying on me
the person number one yeah so like you
just said we are going to dedicate this
podcast to the dads we are going to talk
about dads stories and memories and
funny dancing down of the Father's Day
dad day which shouts out to all you
fathers you guys are the dopest happy
Father's Day joining I know I got a lot
of happy Father's Day
I appreciate it but might be a bit
premature
oh my god it's all over my glasses
celebratory rose water now you know how
I feel when I wear my glasses and you're
like you want to go to the store and
like I can't it's raining I need 10
minutes without putting my contacts
because I can't just like it's terrible
it's terrible when it's like hot rain
too and then not only are your glasses
with a piece [ __ ] it's worth when your
girlfriend's of the rain and she's
spraying rose water in your face no
honey this is rose water this isn't rain
this is really nice Gotha training you
know I'm entered this one time and then
all of a sudden I can't find it in my
local beauty supply store anymore it's
like everyone caught on to my secret and
they're gone oh this character I like
her and he's not like Jenna's that's
just a lot of us she's not quite mark
she's somewhere in the middle she's a
fake
delicious of fish no matter time we are
at bed low which is an alcohol service
oh my god yes that was so fun there's
this guy that works there that is like
too much he's eccentric
he's very time he's so friendly but you
walk in the doors like hey you guys yeah
yeah it's really demeaning because I'm
like I don't think kids behind
thank you that much older than me
personally but so he's like way too much
but I was it was super hot out it was
midday on like a weekend like fourth of
July or something and we're there with
Brett and we're like getting all these
like ciders and stuff so I pulled my
rose water which is just it's aloe herbs
minerals and hyaluronic acid and it
feels really refreshing you nice and
helps like moisturize your skin and like
keep it feel really good there's a bunch
of different ways I've Linda flower one
like all different I like I like them I
carry them with me to feel really great
and I was sweating and hot so I pulled
them out of my bag as he's ringing up
our thousand bottles of alcohol that
we're gonna drink later and I sprayed it
on my face and I asked Brett if you
wanted some because he like with it too
really quick the manner in which you
pulled it I was like it was almost like
you pulled out I don't know a fan you
know people taught fans us are paying so
she did so quick she just pulled out and
sprayed herself like it was all such a
quick fluid movement yeah a lot of
people might kind of and she looks at me
and goes oh what the [ __ ] is that
and I was like it's rose water it feels
good it's hot out and he was like hey
here's a quick moment wish I was in
crackheads yeah the crackhead moment we
in bed eyes and I was like spraying my
face makes me a crackhead
yeah it was pretty funny you sir are too
much 24/7 and I'm the crackhead [ __ ] out
of here while his choice of words may
have been inappropriate I agreed with
him on the sentiments that it was
intense and a lot when she whipped it up
right it feels good did you show quick
she did that I don't know if you say no
Sean I tell you anything I'm Julie blind
Mike I am you a brushed and moisturize
and great and everyone can be jealous of
rosewater until you get some
organization do you know how many of
these that go through yeah I do okay
my arm is feeling so just a computer
that's our computer tower I'm feeling so
light and refreshed returned to you by
the Bellas product oh my god I was not
brought to you by rosewater it came by
tracker in the skin but now you can read
about realm on okay so if you lean to
rosewater you can attach track do OSI
track report and remember Rosa you can
actually exactly like I attach it like
reverently please just put it around man
please okay can you take off the lid no
just jamming on their average so why are
you doing it like that okay I need to be
able to find my rose water from wherever
I am please God you Wow thanks so much I
do the thing with your phone
we're having fun this is fun oh my god
yeah oh yeah God your headphones are
drenched the topic woman it's hot out
okay we're air conditioned studio it's a
hundred boiling degrees yeah you guys
just like because it's not our act like
it's hot in here as a formality point
you how you either wait so and my crack
has forgotten it that's a question to be
determined laid there and I like forever
having a moment I think you might be for
having a cracking moment I wouldn't call
you a crack it per se what I have to do
crack in order to be a crackhead well
that's debatable
see ya yeah why cuz you got called a
crackhead in public by someone without
crack is okay speaking of getting calls
is speaking of getting called names
please forgive me for saying this word
out loud and make sure that you
understand the context because it's a
terrible worry aboard cracker no [ __ ]
either called a [ __ ] on elder scrolls
online for the first site life
sorry for saying it but like you know
you've heard especially when I was
younger like people would say that word
a lot like you you even look at movies
that were made 10 years ago it was okay
right like I said it in the past because
it used to be like a word to say until
you realize how offensive it was people
are alive today and pretty unheard of
that people say that white people don't
use that anymore because it's really
hurtful
yes but til I got called that on
elderscrolls like someone took the time
to whisper it to me right way they typed
it out I was like oh like wait does that
make me like an official person that
plays video games because I got called
the f-word how many hours in outer scope
does it take you to get called that word
because that seems a little lame the
game when I have been singing dude I was
lying Pub G for like I don't know a
month and I called it look if you don't
know area chat a lobby you hear worse
than that nobody said it to me he
whispered it directly at me Oh rocket
League people will tell me that man yeah
like it yeah like they [ __ ] up your play
and you're like oh thanks dude like
sarcastically and there's like some
laboratory words I hurt I hurt my
feelings so bad
it's crazy though because it's obviously
like not in okay word and it's a sense
of and derogatory but if you like
there's I can name like five movies
outside my head right now that like yeah
and like that we're totally okay like
stuck on you yeah right film use the
word when I worded it up the office you
guys were saggy and it's like I mean I
know we're saying is it's so bad right
now but you know what I mean it's just a
crazy like you look literally 10 years
back and it was it was just everywhere I
know it's like nowhere which I like it
this way it's not right but at the same
time it's crazy to see it come back in
those circumstances I think we're like
oh they might need out to tasker you
just like a total like bigot or whatever
you know yeah I don't know but I got a
called that word so I've been called a
crackhead in public to my face and I've
been called you efforts on Elvis girl
looks readable but that's pretty mild
for online video games yeah but it's not
like we are an area chat and we were
like one-on-one just really do something
a prom dinner yeah so we're in a dungeon
and
this girl was on her headset she kept
like being like I feeling I did this but
like they weren't doing the dungeon
right so of course she's really keep
dying so I wasn't on my headset at all
but then so we get to like the final
boss or whatever and that's what my
controller went out and so my character
just started like running to the corner
and then stay there because I exchanged
the batteries in my controller like it
disconnects it very new fault right so
then she was like talking [ __ ] to me on
the headset she was like wow way to go
we just died again because our healer
doesn't know how to heal and I was yet
she's like a level 100 and I'm like Joe
and I learned I turned because I hadn't
had to have I go I'm sorry my controller
died just relax fam I said something
like that so then he the other guy in
the dungeon whispered at me the F word
and I was like are you kidding me and I
was really pissed and it hurt my
feelings and I didn't like it what sort
of touch with that girl was like one of
the if you ever play video games with
somebody that's like really snarky and
thinks that they know everything but
really also isn't that good you know
what I mean that was her [ __ ] gnarly
dude get away from you should say things
like I need healing like oh my god our
heroes I love when people act like
healers are just like a print they're
like it's like they're demanding their
healer I got the [ __ ] player online
too but as she's standing like in a
circle of red just taking like thousands
of points of damage yeah she's like I
need a healer like want you to step out
that damaged zone or as Jason likes it
all I don't stand it stupid why are you
saying ending in stupid a good way to
put it and now we segue out of the Elder
Scrolls action into literally anything
else I'm just kidding I'm just kidding I
love you don't squeeze right I'm
certainly layer
yeah I'm massages I'm on screen the
other day like I gave her a live body
massage man let me started working out
with a new trainer and we're doing the
program and so I'm tiny went from 0 to
60 so our bodies are pretty beat up but
anyways well I don't take less you guys
anyways about the dads ok I'm going to
leave this off go ahead so hey
Mina Franz follow me a big shout-out to
France Almeida and Tom Morey to the
dopest Avenue I I really just want to
start with this one because I feel like
it's kind of relevant to recent news
that happen my dad yeah I don't think
you know my dad worked with a lot of and
still does works with a lot of you know
very influential pretty famous people he
worked in he worked at NBC Universal he
worked at ABC Universal he worked as a
stand-up comedian for 20 years he went
on the Craig Ferguson show as a comedian
like he's incredibly accomplished
comedian but also you know director and
producer of all sorts of things one of
the people that he got to meet and work
with with Adam West who recently passed
which was incredibly sad but Adam West
for those who don't know was the
original Batman like he is he's the
batty that meant he is Batman when you
think of Batman you think about him left
and when I was a kid I loved Batman like
all kids and for my birthday one year my
dad literally arranged with Adam West to
call me on my birthday
as Batman and so Batman called me on my
birthday and doing the Batman voice and
I was losing my [ __ ] mind I was like
holy [ __ ] Batman called me and the
craziest thing about it is it could have
been anyone oh it was literally Batman
you know I mean and yeah so that was
that was one that I want to start off
with because he recently passed and
that's just like my dad remaining he's
saying you got a phone call one time
from Adam let him surround was himself I
said that's [ __ ] up I gotta have a
knife you had lucky kid I am lucky and
my dad reminded me of that story and I
was like holy [ __ ] like I totally forgot
about how legend that was that's kind
anything yeah anyway your turn I feel
like I told a lot of my dad story
probably off in like older videos and
stuff like that so if you like watched a
lot of my videos you probably know some
of these and I apologize but I also
imagine there's a fair amount of people
that have not seen those videos that
would appreciate let's just assume no
one has seen any of them
so if you're hearing repeat stories
sorry
well okay so this one it was not I'm
actually not I wasn't sure if I told us
but it was not me it was my brother who
is pretty awesome yeah a man he's been
in a lot of Jenna stories so I really
like I love my dad's cooking my dad's
like a really good cook yeah he took
that spaghetti sauce rescue from him
that he is it's like my literal favorite
favorite food even I'm a vegan now like
I'm dying to figure out a way to make
those meatballs in that sauce vegan
because it's just for your childhood it
is it is my complete childhood but he's
also used to make tons of other great
stuff for us and I always really liked
it but he was very traditional sort of
like cook so he would always have like
our meat vegetables potatoes he's meaner
no starch
except for he would make us like a bean
soup with like seven literally 70
different kinds of beans in it and I
remember he started dating my stepmom
and she was like no no you're not making
that anymore we're like what what do you
mean no may be nice to be so surprised
like [ __ ] no successes come are you see
that it was just like abroad but just
like a billion me isn't it I mean all
they were it wasn't like if you actually
guess how many type of beans not
exaggerating I like 50 or 70 yeah I'm
not kidding it was like it was next
level Phoenix I give you how many
minerals are you getting it's like an
you take a giant pot of water and then
you just dump in every kind of being
ever and just turn on the heat and let
it simmer like that I've you into like
ancient so many grocery stores and I can
only name like six beans I mean maybe
that's too high but it was called
something like that like the sea beans
anniversary I Stephanie do you see if I
don't remember I can grace but I really
liked it and it has like little pieces
of ham in it then you put in there I'm
like dad I like ha's bucks
anyways I would like to a lot of beans
but so my dad uh one night we were a
little bit old I was maybe like 10 my
brother was like 13 or 12 she's not 13
is like still sort of a child but my dad
made pork chops and I'm sitting there
and I loved pork chops and I was
like here my pork chop you know of
course I mean it was like Apple and rice
and it was like really tasty and I was
having a great time and just minding my
own business and then you know we
finished dinner and my dad goes upstairs
and he's like well why doesn't the
toilet work and he's like you know sort
of doing this thing and like flushing
and plunging it clear was referring that
that house that he lived in only had one
bathroom yeah one bathroom just upstairs
it was just one bathroom for the whole
house so like if you have to go back and
you gotta go upstairs and go in there so
of course he realized right away that it
was clogged so my dad is I guess a true
dad and that if there's a problem he
fixes it himself like my dad kind of got
a call and plumber call someone to fix
something
so the toilets clogged and he can unclog
it so what does my dad do he gets his
tools and he takes the entire toilet off
the floor off the floor I had never seen
it I didn't know what it looks like
under a toilet like it's a floor the
pipe and I'm like what the [ __ ] dude dad
just took the toilet off the floor and
so he like reaches into the pipe to
figure out the clutch that's the most
dancing I've ever like most important
cities like I was like thank you so much
oh my gosh just sitting there like oh
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] my dad just took the
toilet off the ground and exposed me
like there's no tomorrow
my brother didn't like the pork chop so
he fold it into his napkin one upstairs
and flushed it down the toilet
the whole pork chop am I can you see
exposed him oh my god that's so bad I
know but then my dad was like I'm not
mad at you just tell me the truth if you
didn't want a pork chop I would have
made you something else ever it's like
okay lesson learned
yeah but like as a kid you wonder you're
like Maine Sears is like tone inside
your pants cooking like don't ever say
no to well one of your main fears is
like your parent finding out that like
you lie
know that that's a real pork chop in a
toilet situation if you know in part
yeah like my dad was really nice about
it he wasn't mad he was just like you
know just don't don't like tell me you
don't like it and I'll make you
something else and it's not a big deal
you didn't have to go flush it down the
toilet yeah I guess like if I was a
parent I feel bad - I'm like well you
really did like it that bad okay I would
have made you something else I want you
to be hungry you know
yeah that's so funny man yeah she took
the toilet off the floor for this day I
still have not ever seen someone take a
[Music]
toilet off the floor oh you know what
that is I think that's our tracker pixel
lead you grab that for me tracker
picture whatever just on my phone all
the way across the room by using it that
was amazing thank you that I didn't know
where my phone was addicted probably
work thank you oh my god Thank You
tracker pixel for that guy's I would
have just lost my phone in this me and I
found it with my tracker pixel which
right here I just pressed the button on
the tracker pixel and it played a noise
on my phone because I lost my phone so
you can find your phone with the tracker
pixel or you can also find your tracker
pixel with your phone
hey you attach this devices this device
the things that you lose all the time
your keys your wallet your drone your
backpack anything it's important to you
that you feel like you might lose or do
lose this is the lightest Bluetooth
tracking device on the market
you put track tracker pixel whatever you
lose things it's small enough to say
anywhere and it has this little hanging
just a little it's really strong I don't
know if this little cord on it which is
really nice when you misplace an item
that has tracker pixel attached to use
your smartphone and a 90 decibel alert
will help you find it in second even has
an LED light on it so you can find it in
the dark alright I'll show you okay can
work you know that and just have fun
around bumpers get done whatever I guess
oh my god oh my god this is so fun guys
if you lost your phone just press the
button your tracker pixel and your phone
rings just like that and you can find
your - odd item even if it's miles away
because every tracker user is part of
the largest crab network in the world
which makes this really awesome
anytime you're traveling with stuff you
know is it trackers 30 day money-back
guarantee means you truly have nothing
to lose go to the tracker that's th e TR
ACK are no e
tomoco Jimmy Julian 20 bucks off any
order can't recommend this device enough
really awesome it's worth it you all
lose your stuff anymore also the skin
guys do you want your news waiting for
you when you wake up in the morning get
the skin it's free it's not just a
retrial it's not just sign up and pay
later it is free okay the skin makes it
easy for you to know what's up with the
latest on world news politics sports
entertainment and eats more guys think
the top news headlines and all the
import other important stuff you want to
know all in one condensed nice organized
email for you to just consume its
content it's the easiest way to get your
info in the morning guys four million
people right now waking up to the skin
Oprah links up to the skin guys come on
do you need anything else I just sell it
um Oprah wakes up to the skin guys right
now you can keep up with any
conversation at work even if you're
tired and you're getting coughing you're
like hey Jim why are you bothering me
I'm trying to caffeinate
he's talking about politics well you
know I read the skin today I'm going to
just like shut this boy down and expose
him and then I'm going to Casa de right
now go to the skin that's th es ki mmm
calm / and Julian you have a chance to
win a $250 Visa gift card and you start
right now by going to the skin calm and
signing up thank you to our sponsor
thank you guys I hate you you're a
little trolley troll you know it's all
true
all right what kind of dad sorry you
guys right so I'm gonna this is a good
one
so mom my dad a lot of my life time was
a comedian which means I mean he's
always going to the community but I'm is
I don't need to get job professionally
yeah he I had guys all the dad jokes
that you might ever face I had 10 times
worse okay my dad was a comedian it was
the worst mess so when he stopped
working as a comedian doing shows doing
stand-up and got a job 9 to 5 job
everyone's schedule was different right
because like you're not used to dad
being out at odd hours or days or the
week to a weekend or ever to work he's
now 9:00 to 5:00 so when he left in the
morning to the I think it was ABC when
he got that first job after being medium
for so long he
to work and on his first day I was like
where you going because like he never
like left in the morning to work and he
was like I gotta I gotta go to work like
I have a job nothing okay so he goes to
work and you know he works a full day
and comes back and the next morning he's
getting ready again and I'm like where
you going
he's like work and I'm like again like
why are you going twice so like that was
a conversation that he he and I had and
I remembered and actually he remembered
that shit's funny because like in your
mind as kid you like the concepts of
work is like you gotta go to work okay
you're done with it well especially when
you're like you're you see your dad's
schedule being a certain way and he
doesn't go places in the morning and
you're like well I thought you worked
yes yeah you're trying to saw and then
you're done what are you doing doing why
doing it again are you doing you already
did work yeah that's a short one but I
you want to go again yeah really got you
you're cute
okay so my dad in addition to being
comedian he is a filmmaker and so
needless to say a lot of our childhood
was on film because he would be filming
us whatever we're doing like he films us
playing baseball he held me up on how I
tapes but one of the bigger things one
of the bigger I would say endeavors we
did filmmaking was as children was
recreating the YouTube music video for
elevation with me and my brother so we
love this song so much I don't know why
elevation I usually like it was just our
little stupid song we listened to over
and over and so finally one Saturday of
Adele's like you know what let's go down
to Santa Monica beach I'll bring the
camera and I'm going to direct a music
video with YouTube so we filmed an
entire music video to Elevation and it
still exists like I can I kept
everything I'm sure he has it and I
think if there's enough demand for it I
might you man demand what am I thinking
I mean people are I demand people are
obviously gonna want to see it anyway we
he like choreograph these different
movements over these pillars I don't
without the sandbox a beach any of you
but there's that grass area with those
with those columns and pillars it's like
a little walkway and it's a grass Hill
there's that one specific spot I
actually don't even know if so that but
it was and we did this this one shot
that I remember very distinctly where
rim criss cross through and out of the
pillars and my dad tracked us with his
camera I mean this is the real this is
the real thing that so we created music
videos just kind of one of the
filmmaking endeavors as I did ideas kit
and while we're on the topic is film a
game might as well say some of the other
[ __ ] that we did we did something called
petunias which a lot of you sneaky
[ __ ] have already known we call
ourselves pooch and so we made couch
news because we thought when you thought
something was funny or cute or whatever
you just say that's pooch what the hell
that's really sad
Bosley said like I don't know how to
describe it okay it was like a weird kid
lingo but like which means dog right so
dogs and shoots when you're disciplining
those cute it's like pooch so we made it
not try to make poo tapping yeah we're
not having oh my god it happens I'm
trying to expect to happen okay so they
never gonna happen news was basically me
and my brother filming on my dad's flip
cam pretending that we were news anchors
and it was the literal dumbest thing
I've done with any of my time on earth
and it's still existent no [ __ ] more
of you in the final you know you already
found it so that's that's a my dad would
basically orchestrated the whole thing
so we would do this thing where Marlon
and I were the anchors in the studio my
dad was the reporter on the street but
he's just in the front seat in the car
we're in the back you my god so he'd be
like he'd be like all right start with
you guys it was like hey today I'm
pushing uh and we have in the field man
and he's like he's like yelling I got a
star but he can't carry back to me like
oh that was [ __ ] weird but yeah that
was um that was a segment best thing we
did together it was good times that's a
really cute foot can remember those
[Music]
alright I'm done I can tell you that's
really cute that you're cute I can tell
you sorry about
I think of a video recently I told the
story
well like one of the only times that
I've seen my dad like actually an ad was
when we're like waiting in McDonald's my
dad went to movie as McDonald's and I
had like my cat's cradle string on
either both of my feet through the
handle bar in the car and I was going
like this is my feet and it's odd to the
is like once you beat X I saw my dad
like really angry so it felt so good
like your feet and pieces of string
hanging from his fingers going like this
with my feet and accidentally sawed
through like the handlebars and he's
like one year ago there's ever seen him
like really [ __ ] angry but another
time one of the only other times what
I've ever seen him pretty [ __ ] angry
like not not mad like that because I
didn't do anything like bad per se was
like water gross
oh brother how much to drink him solid
outside I was going to tell you being
oyster [ __ ] up [ __ ] he wasn't mad like
that but he was mad sort of disappointed
no it was yeah so my dad is my baseball
coach and I played baseball for like a
long time until I was like 13 or
something and then I played softball but
I played baseball from like you know six
to thirteen there's whatever and I was
on this team and it was like almost all
boys and I played second base and
outfield and we were like really good my
dad was a really great coach and he like
he was really great because he would
always give everybody equal play time
like you know we have someone on our
team with rheumatoid arthritis or like
you know people who don't play other
sports or like actual illnesses that
like prevent them from playing but like
my dad was really good about having a
kids team means everybody plays all the
time you figure out you work together in
a roadie has at the time a board of
Lillian exactly and but there were other
lumic teams that was very corrupt
Oh trust me I saw all that right yeah I
was like really sad and like they didn't
mean it really hurts my heart but my dad
was on like that and it wasn't just
about winning it was always about having
fun we knew that and he like really made
sure that everybody got that all the
time and it's about playing with people
and you know whatever so we were
actually really really good because we
have like a bunch of people on our team
that were really good and we were in
like the Lilly
championship game which is what you work
all summer towards or whatever right for
your season here and it was the game it
was whatever it was this [ __ ] like it
boils down to this and we're like we're
doing so great we're up I like you know
as many runs as you can be until the
mercy laughs and a batting six runs and
we're just like cruising looks like this
is in the bag what a wonderful summer
day it's like you know the sun's
starting to go down it's like super
great like everything is so fantastic
well this can't bend on our team I want
to say this in the kindest way possible
but then was a heftier kid and Ben's mom
the kind of mom to bring everybody
full-sized Snickers after the gamer drug
and so Ben it's like the fifth inning or
something and we're out by like ten runs
like there's no way we could lose then
comes into the dugout with something
I've never seen before because Ben's mom
lets Ben go to the concession stand in
the middle of the game and boxes are
containers the concession stand is there
for the fans and like people that are
parents to buy you know candy or you
know you're in it
exactly Stan's allowed to go to the
concession stand by himself smack in the
middle of games which my dad made very
clear was not the rule so you don't
leave the dugout or a supports each
other
but somehow been snuck away and also
figured since it's a championship game
I'm going that concession sim that comes
back with something I've never seen
before which is you know a pixie stick
yeah
like the little one in the pain grows
teeny tiny
get back was I get to sweat plastic
particular you receive it is sacred it's
as big as the world like it continues
it's like the size of Oslo yeah more
like whoa man what is that oh my god
never seen a patient stick like that in
my life okay so not a sugar is like a
leader of code yeah so been dumping it
down girl it's all like a bag do you eat
some my dad keeps looking back being
like where did you guys get that and
we're like man guys man okay and he's
like all right well you know us I
supposed to be eating that but like it's
the championship game like have fun so
we all slowly and surely convinced our
parents that we need giant Pixy sticks
because it's especially thank you
special game and we're winning so
somebody's parent bought us like all of
it like the entire dugout all a giant
Pixy stick and we're just back there
like knocking them back like having a
great time I'm like wow man this is the
greatest idea with a okay and we're like
sugar high a party on mines and then you
start hearing this like knock cheer like
knock cheer and we're getting [ __ ]
rocked like they're just hitting home
runs large triple-double and we're just
like what our pinkie things like oh we
lost that [ __ ] game like from 85 to
89 it just like ran when we played like
[ __ ] you set up so many runs because no
we could focus we got so sugar high and
that was one of the only times I've seen
my dad like genuinely angry like what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing so insane
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing we were
like I don't know that's a Little League
story be Pixy sticks sorry we can't
waste a conversation about it's just for
fun and hope we had fun cuz yet today we
had a ton of fun
oh my god
it adds lire it's not about fun it's
about not eating giant Pixy sticks put
such a little league story I can't even
think of any anymore right all the
Little League story like kids conspiring
against the coach - just like sabotage
we didn't think we were doing anything
bad yeah you were just found tasty
sticks I mean it's like it was amazing
like the feeling of being on that takes
you sick as a child is like it's like
the first time you get drunk it's like
it's a drug yeah being sugar high isn't
okay
you cannot control not just sugar high
of like having a candy bar like having
literal sugar poured into a stick and
just consuming wheel and wash you have
those like I couldn't uh I couldn't
function it was like I was out of body
then massage just like yeah this is like
the ha feel everyday like [ __ ] Ben for
doing that to everybody but also like
Ben you know how to have fun
dr. Ben right you still having those
tasty takes or what I we marry like said
that was the best but he was a bad
influence
we shouldn't just eat it sugar the
entire game and he's nuts
yeah times so funny it was we blew that
game and my dad was pissed because he
was our coach you know he worked with us
like all [ __ ] summer whatever all
seasons
my game is no [ __ ] joke I mean you
don't know not of what makes a
championship game you have none it so
together I see the playoffs theater
that's when we did and just a bunch of
plastic Pixy 6 ruined it all mm-hmm he
threw it away that was funny
Pixy Stix he was knockin about a stick
he wasn't as bad as when I saw the
handle in half but he was pretty mad he
loved the pretty mad at Ben's mom that's
an irresponsible mom man
tbh Ben's life look Sophie dude you got
another dad's diary I can't think of any
like really good ones after that okay I
know that I know there were more there's
like a lot of goofy show we did and my
dad's filmed it you know but kind of
things like I'm blanking I know as soon
as we stop recording there's gonna be
more than I remember and they will do it
apart - next others
or something but yeah I'm kind of kind
of a lot what about you
no I mean I told the other one though
yeah Rosie
no I feel like I've told some of my
bottom yeah but um well that was fun
now let's find shops out to dab shots
after dad's shadow to Dad's and all the
funny memories that you might have with
your dad it's fun to remember Nina do
you get cites in the comments leave us
your dad's or in the comments and also
what you think of our dad sorry it's one
remember these these moments years later
after like not remembering them and then
when you when you reminded them or you
talk to your brother sister dad about
them and then you remember them yeah
it's like like wow that was that was so
insane that's like a big moment it was
such a funny thing that happened and it
it's still a memory you know it's crazy
to think about how many memories there
are yeah you have a kid put the dad but
yeah hope you guys enjoyed these sad
stories yeah you look hot you need some
rose water I really can't see anything
it looks like it looks like this blur
are you guys are completely out of focus
well thank you guys what are you high on
us I'm not I feel great you know you
gotta have two rosewater head not Ben's
mom we'll see you guys next for you guys
in the next one guys really appreciate
you guys being here
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]